[Music]
[Applause]
he captivated the golf audience even
bigger than that uh Michael block PGA
professional tied for 15th at the PGA
Championship and uh kind enough to join
us this morning is this all set in yet
Mike
you know not even close Dan uh it's
insane I it hasn't stopped uh had a good
time with my friends and family right
after uh the PGA Championship on Sunday
night and
at 7 30 in the morning I was back at Oak
Hill doing some interviews and on a
plane at noon and just arrived last
night came in here uh checked in I'm
sitting right now inside the colonial uh
card room in the men's lounge and uh
it's uh it's surreal and it's great and
I've got a lot of people coming up to me
that uh I've looked up to and watched on
TV a lot coming up in uh saying congrats
it's been a really cool experience to
say the least okay some of the people
that you've met or congratulated or
reached out give us an idea
oh boy
um
well any every single person on walks by
me here on the tour you know uh is
literally even cooler than that to be
honest is me uh just now getting an
omelette for breakfast and a Gentleman
making me an omelette shook my hand and
uh congratulated me and then when I was
registering the fourth the four the four
ladies at registration uh all uh wanted
pictures with me and and when I was
coming through the gate even better so
the the gentleman at the gate as soon as
I started driving by they started
yelling and screaming block party
um as I was driving away so it is it's
even more so really cool stuff like that
you know one of my best friends is
Albert Pujols and uh he's he's reached
out to me throughout the entire week and
being around guys like that being around
you know Patrick Cantley who I play a
lot with and uh bojas are back in Orange
County California they've all made me
very comfortable um being around the
scenario and stuff like that so it's
it's been awesome and honestly I have so
many texts and emails and DMs I it is it
is beyond me and I've missed and haven't
been able to respond to so many people
and I apologize and I'll I promise I'll
probably get back to you next week at
some point
why do you think you connected with this
gallery
it's because I'm the guy that's usually
sitting in the stands drinking an IPA
and
um somehow uh the and I'm in the NBA
finals and the coach says you know what
he looks like a good basketball player
come on in and play game seven for us
and then hit a three
um that doesn't happen in any other
sport outside of golf you know this is
the only sport that I know of personally
where a club professional a guy that
teaches golf a guy that runs a golf
course can all of a sudden go play with
the best players in the world in one of
the biggest stages in the world
you handled it so well until I think it
really sunk in and then you didn't you
couldn't handle it the way you do like
you can laugh and joke and hi and
everybody notes all of a sudden the
tears start uh and then you can't stop
them how surprised were you that that
emotion was there and it finally came to
the surface
I'll tell you what uh I haven't really
been that emotional of a human being
outside of watching Rudy you know when
he when they put the jerseys down to
have Rudy come in I mean I cried there I
never cried when I had my kid I cried I
cried when I won the club professional
National Championship in 2014. that's
the first time my wife had seen me cry
and I haven't cried since then and now I
think I've cried about a thousand times
in the last week so now I'm sitting
there I just watch videos now I'm
watching videos of things and people
commenting about me or or um saying
something nice about me and uh Tears
start coming to my eyes again I mean
it's it's crazy how emotional this has
made me
where's the ball from the hole in one
it's funny you said that today was the
first time you know I was just unpacking
my stuff at the house and
um I reached in there and I I have the
ball I've got the glove I've got uh my
yardage book with the pin locations on
it
um and I'll tell you something funny Dan
um the craziest part is about all this
and you're kind of standing on the
memorabilia part
um I've had multiple offers for that
seven iron uh in numbers that I can't
even imagine uh that are more than what
I made the first year I was an assistant
Pro let's just say that
um for that seven iron that I used on a
whole uh 16. are you gonna sell it or
15.
are you gonna sell them I don't I don't
know they're 12 years old I need new
irons I literally have no grooves on my
irons
my 997 iron are grooveless uh I
literally have to play in certain
conditions where it's gonna roll out
more it's not going to stick as much so
I've had the same set of items forever
I've never had them regrouped once and
if you saw my irons you wouldn't even
believe it I mean they look like they're
from the thrift store
well you could sell the the ball or do
you want to keep that
uh I I honestly I haven't thought about
it um
you know I definitely want to keep some
stuff so remember to you know really
remember that that uh circumstance and
that what happened and being with Rory
and Sunday and all this stuff uh yeah
we'll see I haven't thought they're just
all sitting right next to my bed right
now uh yeah so I don't lose them
uh moving forward does your rate go up
as a teaching pro
no I've never I've been told I've been
should have been charging a lot more for
a long long time uh and I honestly don't
believe in the fact that I should be
charging more than 150 bucks for a golf
lesson uh I don't care if it's the best
golf lesson of your life it's I think
150 bucks is a really fair price and uh
yeah I know I I don't plan on doing that
whatsoever
and you get to play with Justin Rose and
Rory McIlroy I mean
anything that then can you keep it white
do they keep it light like how do you
like how do you you're playing in the
PGA Championship but still
if these guys have ideas of winning the
thing
so I didn't look at Justin really
outside of meeting him uh I would stare
at his shoes just so I didn't think like
I remember the first call I was just
looking at his shoes when he teed off
um because I didn't want to have that
thought like holy crap I'm teeing off
right now Justin Rose because I've
watched in my whole life I've watched
him at that three wood behind uh 18 of
Marion to win the open uh and then when
Rory hit I'm just like I'm not even
gonna watch this ball flight because I
didn't want to even see it so if you
watch me when I'm on the First Tee uh
with Rory on Sunday I turn around I turn
around I'm not even watching this I I
only probably watch like maybe four
shots that he hit because he's such an
intimidating human being as far as how
he hits the golf ball
if you're picking the actor to play you
in the Michael block movie
Kevin Costner
but I know I I know he might be a little
older than uh I am for that but at this
point but oh boy I don't I though I have
no idea I'll I'll do it hey you you
played the role quite well this past
weekend and uh have fun in Fort Worth
and will life be normal when you go back
home
oh no oh no
um it's gonna be insane you know it's
gonna yeah it will calm down you know a
month from now or whatever it might be
uh but I can't wait to go back and
obviously see my boys and see my friends
back there that didn't make it my
assistant froze in the shop who have
been covering my butt as I've been you
know living this dream they're there
answering phone calls from all these
people and still working their jobs
still you know making sure that payroll
is done still making sure that
everyone's getting paid back at the club
and uh so I haven't had that opportunity
and uh this is a shout out to everyone
back at Arroyo tributical and Mission
Viejo that uh thanks for doing what
you're doing any thoughts on being in
the media
yeah
I've I've had I've I've gotten some
calls on that too
um it's never been a thought in my life
uh
Dan I I have no idea um if if it happens
someday great uh because I know I'm not
gonna be able to play golf my entire
life so uh yeah maybe we'll see I hope
so who knows
well congrats and uh have fun this week
as well and thanks for the entertainment
thank you Dan appreciate you having me
on that's uh Michael block PGA
professional the rates aren't going up
uh tied for 15th at the PGA Championship